more than 70 percent of adults in the uk  have been vaccinated with a first dose  of a covid19 jabba total of 57.8 million  vaccines have been administered across  the uk between the 8th of december  and the 18th of may with 36.9 million  people  having had their first dose and 20.8  million  having received both doses that's 39.6  of all uk adults having two doses of the  vaccine the vaccine's minister  nadim zahawi has said this is a terrific  achievement  and is testament to the dedication of  nhs workers  volunteers local authorities and civil  servants in every corner of the uk  we're doubling down on efforts to offer  over 50s and the most vulnerable a  second dose  to maximize their protection against  covid19  and that second dose of course coming  eight weeks after the first dose now  rather than 12.  while continuing to progress first doses  for people aged  36 and over